So you're stuck in a dungeon with a 20-sided die
and a dragon is keeping you in the dungeon and
the dragon will only let you out if you
can roll a particular total on the dice.
Now you get to choose what the total is, so
please could you choose me a number that's
bigger than 20.
- (Brady: Uh all right, how about 42?)
- 42,  good number okay so then your challenge is
to roll the die and try to get 42. If
you hit 42 you win, you get to leave the
dungeon; uh if you don't hit 42 then you get
kept in the dungeon with the dragon forever.
Umm so let's give it a go!
- (I get one go?)
- One go.
- (Allright let's let's see how we do, all right. Here)
(we go first roll)
- That's 5. Okay it's a
good start, you haven't gone past 42 yet.
16 - that's also pretty good, 21 we're halfway.
- (Another5 and 16 to be good)
- Be good wouldn't it?
12. So now what do you want to win here?
- (What are we on? 21...33.)
- I think you need another
9 to be home.
- (9 more, okay.)
- Of course smallerthan 9 would be okay.
- (Yeah all right. Oh 6!)
6 so we're still still playing. All right, 3 togo.
- (Come on a 3, lucky 3. Come on! Ah 11)
(I've busted past it.)
- Yeah past 42. It's a bit like
that game where you have to get to 21 without
going over 42. So unfortunately the dragon sees
that you've gone past 42 and it's it's game over.
But I think 42 was quite a good pick because
you had lots of lots of outs along the way uh
you didn't you didn't go out too quickly and
there were lots of possibilities along the way.
Um I think the natural question is, what's the
best number that you could have picked? More
than 20 but the best number, the one that's
most likely to come up when you roll the die.
It's not even obvious that there is such a number
I suppose, maybe they're all equally good. Maybe it
doesn't matter so you should just pick 42. What
do you think about that?
-  (I think)
(if if such a number exists it has to be 40 orless.)
- 40 or less, okay, so you want it so that
you could get it in two rolls.
- (Yeah but- and and it
feels like the highest it could be is double the)
(number otherwise it feels like it just becomes
arbitrary after you get to double the highest number.)
Yeah so that's that's the right intuition;
that um to start off with the the effects of
finite size of the die matter really quite a lot
and then in the long run things even out. And we
can even be a bit precise about how things even
out. So eventually you're getting large numbers - you
picked a target number that was a billion and
three or something. So after a while you're
rolling and rolling and I guess you're still alive
because you haven't got to a billion and three yet.
The die has an average; it has an average number
that it that it rolls on average which over the
long run as you're trying to get to a billion um
that's kind of what your experience is going to
be, that the die has an average. Which means
that you hit every number every so often that
the probability that any particular number comes
up is one in the average length of uh skips that
you take when you roll. The average of a 20-sided
die is 10 and a half I think. So for a very large
number like a billion or something your odds
of seeing that particular number, one billion
and three, about one in ten and a half. Which is that
weird mix of being an approximation while also a
weirdly precise number, which is not great odds.
Question - can you do better than that by picking
a small number? My answer is yes you can. So the
odds that you see 100 - I'm gonna write P for
probability and 100 for the probability that you
see the number 100 - that's like you chose a three
digit number P100 for the target. Well in order to
see 100 think about what the previous number was,
and maybe you saw 99 and then you rolled a 1
or maybe you saw 98 and then you rolled a 2; or
maybe you saw a 97 and then you rolled a 3 and
so on and so on and so on. Or maybe you saw uh 80
and you rolled 20. So there's this sum
you can do to relate this back to the previous
numbers, this is a example of something called
a recurrence relation where I don't know the
number that I'm looking for straight away but I
can work it out in terms of smaller problems to
break down the problem into these smaller parts.
There's a bit of work to do here if I want P100,
it's like I have to keep working backwards through
all these previous numbers. For numbers less than
20 there's also a chance that you just roll it
straight away, that there wasn't any previous roll
at all you just got straight in there and rolledit.
- (But you didn't allow that)
- I think that's- I
think it's a more fun game if you have to pick a
number more than 20. None of this cheeky roll it
straight away on the die, that's why I made you
pick a number bigger than 20. Armed with that
recursion relation you can get a computer to work
out the probabilities that different numbers come
up. And the graph is kind of interesting. So the
graph looks like this; the probability that you
see certain total of 1 is- well something because you
might roll it straight away. The probability that
you see 2 is a little bit larger because you
might roll it straight away or you might roll 1
twice to get your 2. And then in a similar manner
the probabilities get larger and larger up to
20 which is the last number which benefits from
this effect that you could just roll it straight
away. 21 isn't so fortunate; 21 you have to make
it in two rolls. And actually it's quite likely that
you blow past 21 on this 20-sided die. The probability
that you hit 21 is down here somewhere.
- (Oh really low)
It's a lot lower. Somewhere in between the
probabilities for 1 and 20 on the graph. But
then things get a little bit better for a brief
window. The next bit of the graph looks like this
with a sort of arch shape, and at 40 there's a
kink in the graph and then it levels off. And at
60 it smooths out even more and there's another
wobble in the graph and it flattens out towards
this kind of long-term probability of 1 in
10 and a half. But the absolute best point is
like you said Brady, between 20 and 40 there's
some maximum on this on this graph. It turns out
that the number 34 is the best total that you
could give to the dragon - and I just know that
because I've done the calculations and checked
the probabilities that different numbers come
up. If you want to check it you could roll the die
quite a lot and see which different totals come
up; I claim the number 34 comes up more than any
other number bigger than 20.
- (Did I hit 34? 21,)
(33-)
- Oh 33 is pretty close! So around 34 these
numbers are all pretty likely to come up, yeah
So a number around 33 to 35. If I let you pick
a couple of numbers that are near each other, some
sort of little interval maybe, here's the target
I'm aiming for plus or minus 2 then centering
it on 34 is still a good idea but it gets much
more likely if I give you a little interval that
you could hit.
- (If you'd allowed any number though,
20 is the one to pick?)
- Uh yes. Any number, any number
at all, 20 is the most likely to want to come up
on on sums. Just between 1 and 20 things get more
and more likely as you have more and more ways to
make those numbers, plus also the bonus of maybe
rolling them in one and just getting it straight
away on that die. So I guess the the kind of
next best after 20 is really likely to come
up 34 is the next most likely. It's a bit of a
random number, 34, somewhere between 20 and 40.
I suppose the extension to this question is,
what happens if I get stuck in a different
dungeon with a larger dragon who owns a larger
die with more sides on it so it goes to a biggernumber?
- (Well the question- the question I've got)
(before you answer that question, is what if it's-
what if the dragon has the most common die that)
(most people have? A 6-sided die?)
- Yeah a 6-sideddie. There's a very similar picture, a maximum
between 6 and 12 that you should pick as a number
that's going to come up in your running total when
you're on that six-sided die in the dungeon of thedragon.
- (But you want a bigger die, bigger than 20?)
Yeah so there's this kind of smooth pattern that
we get with these dots on the graph which gets
smoother and smoother the more dots that you have.
To get more dots I need more faces on the die. And
the calculations get harder - so just in case you're
trapped in a dungeon with a very large die, it'd
be good to have a rule of thumb or some sort of
heuristic about where this is in terms of I don't
know if this is-
- (A sweet spot?)
- That sweet spot is
somewhere between N and 2N. The sweet spot for
where this kind of curve of the graph hits its
maximum, the best probability that you can pick.
The heuristic or the answer in general to
leading order is that that peak happens at e
minus 1 times n; where e is the number 2.7.... I guess
it comes up in problems like this.
- (Natural log or whatever?)
Yeah the basis of natural
logarithms, but then subtract 1, and multiply
by N. So this is a rule of thumb for where that
maximum lies for very large N which does give
you about 34 for the dragon in our original
problem. Maybe weird that that's not a whole
number; e is irrational so this is never a whole
number no matter how big the die is, um but this
gives you a good approximation to where the
maximum of the function is. There's some really
nice continuous versions of this problem where you
have a die that sort of could roll any number and
it gives us this proper smooth distribution, the
one that's kind of hiding in between the dots,
sort of correct way to join the dots and have
this kind of version of the problem where
the dragon wants you to hit some interval
between some number and some other number.
So there's an application of this to evil numbers.
An evil number is one where the decimal expansion
of that number - so if you take your favorite number
like pi or something 3.14159265 and keep going - and
if you add up the digits, so 3 plus 1 plus
4 plus 1 plus 5 plus 9 and keep going.
If at some point that equals the number
666 then you say that your number is evil.
And bad news - pi is evil. The digits add
up to 666 at some point.
- (At some point.)
You get 666; pi is evil. And there's
some very similar mathematics you can
run to talk about the probabilities
that you hit any particular target.
666 is quite a large number so we're in that
realm of long-term probabilities. And because the
digits could be 1 or 2 or 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9;
the average for what the digits
could be - I guess I'm ignoring zero but zeros don't
really get you anywhere closer to your rolling
total they just delay the inevitable - the average
that you get when you actually make progress on
your total is this which is the number 5 I
think because that top's 45. Because the average
is 5 that means that along the way once the
numbers are large you're running total hits
roughly every one number in five; it's taking jumps
of about five each time so it hits roughly every
fifth number. Not exactly of course, it's random, but
it hits roughly every fifth number. Which means
that unfortunately 20% of numbers are evil; one
in five, 20% of them are evil including
things like the square root of 3 or the
golden ratio turn out to be evil numbers as well.
(Not not e though?)
- I don't know- I don't know if
e is evil. We could try and work it out but
we'd need quite a lot of digits of of e - this keeps
you busy on a rainy day, you need a lot of decimal
digits, I suppose about 100 of them, in order to add
them up and then check oh did you hit exactly 666
or not on your way up. So it's just like the die
rolling problem if you like but with a 9-sided
die. I don't know how to make a 9-sided die but
perhaps that's what the what the digits are doing.
(I like that, I like that pi's evil)
- We've had adifferent definition of evil numbers on Numberphile
before to do with prime numbers but this is
another evil number definition. I've seen a third
one as well so there's another way that people
refer to evil numbers to do with their
binary expansion as well, but I think that's one
for a different Numberphile video to do.
- (You chose)
(666 because of the- you know the biblical famous
biblical reference. I guess you could come up with)
(any cool number. Like 42- and you could call that a Hitchhiker number. Is)
(is pi a Hitchhiker number? Does it hit 42? And thingslike that)
- Well let's see, let's do the graph for-
let's do the graph for adding up numbers up to
9 because 42 is somewhere in between multiple
rules of nine so maybe it's near a maximum
of one of those. Maybe it's more likely to
come up than 666 in our digits. Let's do the
graph I suppose, calculate some probabilities.
Footnote: I maybe didn't mean to have the 3
plus at the start, um maybe even numbers just use
the decimal digits I can't remember. In my
defense all of this is made up anyway, none
of this really- none of this really matters.
- (It'snot really evil)
- It's not really evil either way.
(You can't call pi evil, everyone loves pi)
- The fractional part
of pi is definitely evil; maybe the 3 saves it.
Thanks to Brilliant for supporting this video.
Now you probably know all about Brilliant by
now, makers of these fantastic courses and
quizzes covering math, logic, data science,
neural networks, computer programming - all sorts
of stuff. I've shown you examples like this
before but I don't think I've ever mentioned how
great they are on your phone or handheld devices.
The seamless design, all the interactive material, it's
an absolute delight. Smooth, great to look at. So you
can be building your skills and knowledge on a
train, or on the bus to work, just sitting around
on the sofa. Now look I'll be honest I can't be
absolutely sure all the people in this footage
are doing Brilliant courses but I like to think
that guy is, and they definitely all should be
on Brilliant. There's so much great stuff on
there, they're always adding more material as
well; this could be the start of your path to a
new career or maybe just a way to sharpen your
mind. Go to brilliant.org/Numberphile to start a
free 30-day trial and you'll get 20% off an annual
plan. Check out the link in the video description.
Yeah they must be looking at Brilliant
...lots of things- it's a beastly prime.
Okay so a beastly prime is one that has
um 666 in it. Now this one has it in a very
special place, right in the middle right. A
beastly prime is one that has 666 so for
example another beastly prime is this one
6661; 26669 is a beastly
prime, there's a whole bunch of these as well.